there's certain last names whether the
kids like it or not you're part of that
brand okay right if your last name's
Kennedy in politics you're part of that
right your last name's Trump I'm sorry
you're part of Obama Clinton Chelsea's
got no choice Chelsea can't go say you
know what I just want to go out there
and do x y z you can't you are a Clinton
right in sports you got Brady those kids
for the rest of their lives Dara Brady
yep Jordan you're a Jordan Gretzky how
many gretzkies are out there you're
locked into those names right the only
other Hanks I know is Merton Hanks I
don't know if you remember Merton Hanks
or not 49 49ers long neck outside of
that there's only one Hanks I know so in
the Hank's family okay uh your your
dad's been pretty you know but we've all
seen the goalcast video where they tell
the story about your dad and you know I
regret doing this I regret he seems very
sincere when he's talking about certain
areas of his life when he's blown up in
Hollywood was was the family the kind of
a family where at night time you guys
had real conversations because what
Kennedy told me is in their family every
night his dad would ask so what do you
think about drugs what's wrong with
cocaine being legal what's wrong with
prostitution what's wrong with this I
mean kids would battle it out and they
would debate because that's what the
identity family dinners were all about
that's what it was and I love that and I
love that almost every family I saw
that's been successful they were in the
community did he say what age that
started it no since you were kids Wow
since you were kids they would debate
was the Hank's family a family where you
talk about serious issues or was it more
about tell us how school was today tell
us how this was today and they kind of
hit you because they're so concerned
because you know Tom Hanks is here and
we want our sons to have a regular life
what what was that like we definitely we
had we had come we we sat at the dinner
table every night you know no phones
just being present with each other and
uh yeah we talked we talked that was
like mandatory my parents you know I
mean it was no phones you know what I'm
saying
um just connecting with each other you
know like with we definitely did that
um was it connecting was it was it a
debate environment or no it wasn't we
did a thing we did High Point low points
so we did like the the high point of our
day and the low point of our day hmm got
it I like that so what was the high
point of your day low point of the day
was there ever a uh because you know for
your debt you said you went to a
conservative School in in LA right is
that the majority of the the peop the
families there were uh from conservative
okay was it a concert was it like a
Catholic private school it was
Episcopalian private school yes okay so
you know but it doesn't seem like but
your parents were they also religious or
not necessarily were their Church going
or no uh uh my mom okay my mama I was
baptized Greek Orthodox my uh my my mom
was Greek and Bulgarian her parents were
from uh my grandfather my Papu was from
Bulgaria and my Yaya my grandmother was
from Greece
and um we were Greek Orthodox Christian
um
not extremely religious but you know
it's more about family and tradition you
know it's not like you know like a
firing Brimstone kind of religion
um you know it's very laid back you know
why I asked that's more about family and
tradition that's what I'm saying but I
am because your mom and dad also their
backgrounds their faith there's
differences so it's a normal thing to
have differences would you say that's
what it was or here's what we are this
is what we believe in here's what the
Hank's family does in our family we do
it doesn't sound like it was that not at
all not at all yeah I think that's
probably why I'm so out why I'm
comfortable being outspoken because I
don't feel like I have any mold that I
have to fit into I don't feel like I
like like what you mentioned about like
the trumps and the clintons and all that
I never felt any sort of pressure
whatsoever to uh fall in line with any
kind of mold and I I'm thankful for that
you know um you know my my pops used to
tell me like hey if you grow up in in
what you find you're passionate about is
being a [ __ ] garbage man then you
know I support you being a garbage
respect you know what I'm saying so yeah
my my family's like really laid back
like that and and I appreciate them and
I love them a lot for that well for many
reasons I think that's very uh they're
very normal people and then they raised
me to be extremely
uh you know they raised me to be humble
okay they they they themselves are very
humble hard-working people they know the
value of hard work they work their asses
off to get to where they are
um they didn't have anything they grew
up you know dirt poor
um so they were always very conscious in
raising me very conscious of the fact
that um I was not raised like any of the
other you know kids my peers growing up
I was I was not raised like anyone can
you tell us what the uh of the other way
of being raised would be in Hollywood
where your parents are super super
famous right what was that like
well let me put it like this right
um out of all the
out of all the you know out of all my
peers I ever had growing up from you
know the time I was in kindergarten to
all the way through High School
um I was probably the least spoiled kid
that I ever met right like there were
kids you know that might have been the
son of like a successful like dentist
you know or an orthodontist that I went
to school with and they were spoiled
rotten you know what I'm saying
my parents could have spoiled me more
than anybody and I was the least spoiled
okay because they they caught they
raised me consciously knowing that if we
give this kid everything he's going to
grow up to be you know a loser or just a
piece of [ __ ] or just have no work ethic
because he's already been giving every
he's already been given everything
um it's about worth it at work work
ethic they knew if they raised me that
way then I would grow up with absolutely
zero work ethic and they were right
because the kids that I grew up with
that were raised like that they're not
doing [ __ ] you know I'm saying that they
were correct so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]